foreign
police divers have been searching
through the nights at a freezing Lake in
solihull near Birmingham emergency
responders were called just after half
past two on Sunday afternoon four
children were pulled from the water
after falling through the ice those
children are now being cared for in
hospital and where any critical
condition on arrival there now there had
been reports of as many as six people in
the water let's get the very latest
that's guys Becky Johnson is at the
scene at morning back in absolutely
horrible horrible story do we know if
there are perhaps still people in that
Lake yet
that is the fear that led specialist
dive teams to work long into the night
here in solihull in freezing conditions
continuing to search the lake when the
initial report went into emergency
services there was a suggestion as many
as six people may have fallen into the
lake after children were seen playing on
the ice now as we know Emergency
Services were able to pull four children
out of the water they were all in a
critical condition they had suffered
cardiac arrest and were being
resuscitated on their way to hospital
yesterday evening but still no update
about the possibility that two more
children could still be missing and so
we do a wait more details from Emergency
Services later today
in the darkness they continued to search
this Lake in solihull for any signs of
life children had been playing on ice
here when they fell in people nearby did
all they could to help
when our firefighters arrived a number
of police officers and members of the
public were in the water trying to reach
and rescue the children
our crews entered the water
swam to the first child
and our specialist trained firefighters
including technical rescue rescued three
further children
the children were in cardiac arrest
they were blue lighted to nearby
hospitals all critically ill but reports
that more people may still be missing
prompted a major search after many hours
had passed they announced they no longer
expected to find anyone else alive
the temperature here has barely risen
above freezing and rescue workers say it
would be impossible to survive in the
icy water for this long it is a
terrifying reminder of the dangers of
the Arctic conditions currently being
felt right across the country and we're
being warned there could be another week
of this weather to come as the country
battles to stay warm emergency workers
say this should be a warning to people
to do all they can to stay safe
foreign
well you can take a little look down at
that Lake here this morning you can
possibly just make out behind me uh the
light that's where the emergency workers
set up a base where those Specialists uh
dive teams were going into the water we
saw them out on inflatable rafts last
night using those long poles to search
meticulously through the Deep freezing
water of that Lake it has caused a huge
amount of shock in this community as you
would imagine and it is those fears that
potentially two more children could
still be in the water that prompted
these extensive searches despite the
conditions I have never seen so many
emergency workers in one place as when
we turned up here yesterday evening
there were dozens of a specially trained
paramedics fire officers police all here
doing absolutely everything they could
to try try to find anyone who may still
be in that water the temperatures are
bitter and that is why very sadly last
night the fire service said they had
concluded that this would now be a
recovery operation they just don't think
it would be possible to survive for many
hours in the very very cold water of
this Lake this morning the search teams
are no longer here we will have to see
if they come back at first light and as
I say we are expecting some update from
the Emergency Services on the condition
of those four children who last night
were fighting for their lives in
hospital
Becky thanks very much indeed a horrible
story of course uh we'll give you any
update that we get just as soon as it
arrives I know clearly the Arctic Blast
has caused significant disruption right
across the country long stretches of the
M25 Motorway have been jammed drivers in
the south east are being asked by
national highways not to travel unless
they absolutely have to
people have been describing to Sky News
how they've been stuck in their cars
through the freezing night
been an absolute standstill for yeah
over three hours so
um yeah it's um it's pretty
disheartening
um I mean that's it the the UK were just
rubbish we are rubbish when the weather
gets extreme aren't we we really are bad
no so I'm I'm meant to be getting home
for Nottingham and home to Nottingham so
um yeah maybe maybe I'll definitely get
home for Christmas maybe that's the plan
we've got a new plan
big problems at the airports as well at
both Gatwick and Stansted had to close
their runways yesterday to clear the
snow they are open again now but with
reduced flights and a huge backlog of
waiting passengers Travelers are being
wanted to check with their carrier
before leaving for the airport I would
like to speak to somebody finds themself
in well at Gatwick Airport Bethany
Wharton has been stranded there and she
joins us on the line and Bethany good to
talk to you and first things first where
were you supposed to be going
uh to Bali
to Bali and instead you're trapped at
Gatwick I mean how long have you been
there for I've been here around 17 hours
17 hours yes
what kind of communication have you
heard from from the airline and from the
uh from the airport have they given you
any idea of when you might be heading
off
um nothing so far
um we spoke to some staff
um when we came back through question
yesterday they said to go back to your
airline just in the morning around eight
o'clock and they'll tell us some more
information but that's all we've heard
and we couldn't get any hotels last
night as everywhere it was fully booked
everyone's in the same position everyone
has just been sleeping on the floor
so how many of you are though Bethany
who's traveling with you at the moment
I'm with my boyfriend at the moment
and
guys managed to call I mean have you
have you managed to grab any sleep
yourselves
um not really I've had a couple of hours
but everyone's in the same situation
there's lots of people children as well
and um everyone's just trying to get
some sleep but it's really cold as well
in here yeah I I can normally I can only
imagine I mean have you at least been
provided with some teas coffees food
anything like that
um no nothing
I haven't had really any help from any
staff
um can't really find anyone to speak to
just been a bit of a nightmare so
Bethany was this you heading off for for
the Christmas period or is this just a
quick trip you were planning no no
one heading out to Australia
yeah oh dear oh dear so what's what's
this going to do for your plans I mean
if if you can't get away today what what
does that message what does that maybe
mean for well for the trip to Bali yeah
so our trip um we'll have to miss out
parts of our trip that we've already
booked um I've also I had to cancel some
things we've already tried to book
already
um I'm not sure if we'll get any money
back from the airline as um they said
they wouldn't even offer us
um money for a hotel for the night
is there is there any thought in your
mind of just jacking it and leaving the
airport going home and getting
yourselves warm and maybe getting some
get maybe getting some sleep
yes I did I did think that last night
before uh before I even tried to sleep
um
but
gonna try again today and then maybe we
will have to go back
and I I I suppose Bethany you must have
been looking forward to this trip for
for quite a long time yes and obviously
we've already said bye to everyone at
home so
oh dear
um well look I I I will be keeping my
fingers crossed Bethany I mean moving to
Australia is it is a big old it's a big
old trip in and of itself but but to
miss it on the barley leg um look well
stay warm and keep in touch and look let
us know if you managed to get on that
plane sometime today I hope you do
thank you you take care of Bethany
uh let's bring in Sky's Becky Cottrell
at Victoria Station in London uh
Victoria good to see you um what what is
the the state of play in terms of
Transport this morning Becky I mean I
know myself from from driving in this
morning the roads are absolutely
treacherous and the fact that people if
they can avoid driving today really
should do but one of the public
transport aspect
foreign
well certainly if you're trying to get
the train you're likely to face problems
today particularly if you're here in the
south east or London I'm at London's
Victoria Station many of the lines here
suspended the companies that operate up
here Southeastern Southern rail the
Gatwick Express they've all had problems
with snow on the tracks overnight as I
say having to cancel services today they
are trying to get them back up and
running but it's likely the disruption
will continue for much of the day and
it's of course not just the conditions
on the track so there are the problem
they're also trying to put on
replacement bus services but if the
conditions on the road simply aren't
good enough then that is not going to be
possible either as you mentioned drivers
also facing a lot of problems we are
getting into Monday rush hour now and as
you said the advice in southeast simply
don't travel unless you absolutely have
to reports of drivers stuck on the roads
in the snow and and as they're trying to
clear that clearly some of the backlog
may clear but it's going to continue for
much of the day so really particularly
if we're here in the southeast stay home
unless you absolutely have to travel
Becky thank you
[Music]
a bit of breaking for you the latest
growth figures for October have just
been published in the last few minutes
at GDP growing by 0.5 in October and
that follows a fall of 0.6 the previous
month which of course was affected by
the state funeral of Queen Elizabeth
will be getting reaction to those
figures from the chancellor later this
morning and he said there is a tough
road ahead at Jeremy Hunt uh in a few
minutes time we'll be speaking to our
economics editor edcon we get the tape
back we'll bring it right to you but it
is not just snow and ice causing
disruption this week rail workers nurses
posties well they're all walking out the
government's emergency Cobra committee
meets this morning and ministers have
made an official request to the military
to drive ambulances during the strikes
here's our political correspondent Rob
Powell
get used to this
the coming days we'll see strikes on the
trains at Royal Mail and in the NHS
now the government is ramping up its
plans to limit disruption with the Cobra
emergency response committee meeting
today troops will also start arriving at
hospitals this week to start training to
drive ambulances a strike by the nurse's
Union is still due on Thursday after the
government rejected their offer of
negotiations overpay
but could this week be just the start
Junior doctors walked out in 2016 for
the first time in four decades ahead of
a ballot next month their Union is clear
about the pay Rises they want now and
the chances of future strikes
I think it's likely unless the
government is willing to negotiate with
us about pay so we're asking for a
reversal of a pay cut we've had you know
a pay cut for junior doctors of 26.1
since 2008 and so over a quarter of our
pay has been lost
it's been calmer than usual here in
recent weeks but Christmas cheer is
probably still in short supply for a
prime minister who has problems piling
up it increasingly feels like the
government is moving from trying to
avert the strikes to just managing their
impact but Rishi sunak is in a tight
spot squeezed on one side by unions
demanding higher pay and on the other by
Tory MPS who are becoming increasingly
vocal by the government's tax and spend
policies
politics aside the end result is a week
ahead where most people will notice the
impact of strike action who they blame
for it will shape the political Fallout
and the fortunes of the Prime Minister
Rob pal Sky News in Westminster
thousands of NHS workers including of
course nurses are scheduled to take part
in strikes across December at the first
of those taking place today when Unison
members working in the NHS in Northern
Ireland will be walking out nurses
across England Wales and Northern
Ireland also striking on the 15th and
the 20th of the month
ambulance workers what about those uh
well those will be taking industrial
action on the 21st and the 28th
postal workers were on picket lines
yesterday for a second day of strikes
this month workers had expected to
continue striking across December
and what about the railways uh rail
strikes taking place over four days this
week and from Christmas Eve until early
on the 27th more also planned to come
January
border for staff driving test examiners
security staff on Eurostar and some
civil servants also walking out this
month
uh our political correspondent Tamara
Cohen is here and a bit of breaking news
on this topic this morning an official
request has been put in uh for the
military to help driving ambulances
what's the significance of this that's
right so the government are ramping up
their contingency plans for these
strikes obviously they're urging the
unions to pull back from the brink and
to call the strikes off but in the
meantime they are preparing for them to
happen and certainly for the ambulances
at strike which begins on the 21st of
December a request has now gone in it's
called a maca request military aid the
civilian authorities and it's basically
a formal request for an army Personnel
to help out with driving with some of
the logistics roles and there are I
understand 600 military personnel who
would be deployed as ambulance drivers
in another 150 as support workers
close to 10 000 ambulance workers yes
are going on strike so they will be in
the coming days going to hospital trust
to learn how it all works because of
course they're not trained as ambulance
drivers they're not trained in all the
logistics around it so it is a worrying
time for anyone who might need one
during that period but they are being
prepared for those roles they're also
being prepared to stand in for the
Border Force who are also going to be
going on strike at various different
airports and ports over the next few
days as well so military personnel
preparing for that they will have their
Christmas leave canceled to do that
because of course they can't go on
strike but we now have strikes in 10
different sectors and there will be a
second Cobra meeting on Wednesday the
first one this afternoon to work out how
exactly the government are going to
respond to the to the challenges posed
by those strikes yeah why do I get the
feeling the military are going to be
particularly busy this Christmas
tomorrow for no thanks very much indeed
let's stick with the story joining us
now Alan Loftis National officer at
Unison Alan very good morning to you and
first of all can I just get your
reaction to that which tomato was just
telling us that official request has
gone into the military to to assist in
terms of of ambulance drivers of course
we're discussing nurses in Northern
Ireland but should we have any concerns
about the military stepping into a rule
that that frankly it is not theirs
I mean I think that the you know all of
our uh ambulance workers uh in unison
respect the military and respect the
support that they're offering but of
course uh as your your correspondent
called us uh ambulance drivers is is far
from the truth actually they're highly
trained
urgent and emergency care workers who
know how to work in the NHS and the
military can't just be put in place of
ambulance workers and and expect that
the service is going to run as normal
um I mean it's a great offer by the
military but it's not going to go
anywhere near
um you know stopping the the strikes and
the walkouts that are due to happen on
the 21st yeah it is a sticking plaster
if if even that and but let's let's talk
about Northern Ireland Ireland and to
what extent should people there expect
services to be disrupted today
well uh you know um Unison when it takes
strike action will work with employers
to put in life and limb cover so I know
that uh you know our health workers
there have been talking to their
employers about making sure that those
um people in serious need will get aid
but it will be disrupted for the public
and this has to be a wake-up call for
the government that's refused to sit
down and just have talks with us and
that's all we've really been asking for
is they're 72 Pence an hour pay rise
that they awarded late last year has not
gone enough to
um you know deal with the problem of the
rising cost of living for many NHS staff
and I think this is the sort of decision
that's never taken lightly by health
staff but we've got to this point after
10 years of austerity that haven't
delivered anything for NHS workers and
they're taking a stand now and the
government really needs to sit down and
talk to us
so just just explain exactly when you
say life in limb cover what does that
refer to I mean it's a phrase I think
people will recognize by perhaps not the
specifics
so it's places like critical care places
like accident emergency and ambulance
services will have a responsibilities
put on life and then cover so the very
very most serious people so if you're in
a cardiac arrest you'd still need to
somebody to come along and give you
life-saving aid but you know the
ambulance service and hospitals are used
often for Urgent uh care as well and I
think Urgent Care is probably which is
going to be most disrupted so there will
be talks and I don't know about exactly
how the talks went in Northern Ireland
but I'm sure that they have got some
cover Arrangements but this is the
willingness of staff to work through
strike and the trouble is if the
government don't start talking to us
that staff will get increasingly
frustrated with this war against them as
they see the rhetoric from the
government and they then may choose not
to provide life and limb cover which is
the place I don't think any of us want
to get to so there's a real urgency for
the government to wake up stop looking
at ways to prevent striking workers from
striking and talk to us about paying the
cost of living
so just to be absolutely clear that um
you you think there may come a point in
the not too distant future if the
government doesn't you know sit down
around the table
where you would remove life and limb
cover
now I'm not saying that we would remove
the limb cover what what happens is you
see we will say to our members who are
able to take their legal right to strike
that we would like you to provide life
and then cover but it's up to that
individual worker whether or not they do
take that up and if enough people get
sick of uh the government rhetoric
against them as they see this you know
attack on striking workers is really an
attack on health workers they may very
well choose them not to come into work
and provide that life and them cover and
we don't want to get to that position so
it's really the government need to sit
down and start talking to us urgently I
I suppose the issue the issue is this
island and look clearly there is an
awful lot of public support for public
sector workers getting a fair deal in
terms of their cash I don't know what it
is like outside the window just to your
left there and you're at sea level
turning ball in the city perhaps you
don't have the have the the ice in the
snow that we have here but you know the
situation that there is across much of
the country today there will be an awful
lot of people having Falls trips spills
and the like not necessarily requiring
immediate urgent care but requiring care
and that's not going to be available
available to many of them today in
Northern Ireland no and you know what
the care is already not available to
people and that goes from Healthcare to
social care this government have allowed
10 years of ruining our Health and Care
Service so staff are taking a stand
against the state of the service I mean
they are people in their own communities
you've got to remember this the health
workers live in their communities that
are served by them and they don't take
these decisions lightly but you know
they know the quality of the care that
they're able to give at the moment
because of the state of their Health
Service is already perilous so yes it's
about pay but it's also about the
quality of the NHS the quality of social
care these are all things that we need
to do something about and urgently
uh and many thanks for joining us that's
Alan Loftis at National officer at
unison
uh plenty coming up on the show this
morning uh first at what to look for if
you think your child might be sick with
strappy and when to seeking help and
that's at around about half pounds
[Music]
we'll also be hearing from Richard
Marquis former head of the U.S
government's investigation into the lock
of the bombing after the arrest of the
suspected bomb maker
[Music]
just after eight we'll be speaking to
live a shadow Minister for Health and
Social care Liz Campbell
thank you
now Ukraine's President Vladimir
zielinski has held talks with the
leaders of the United States turkey and
France with daytime temperatures barely
Rising above freezing Russia has been
hitting the country's power stations
more than a million homes in the port
city of Odessa have been without
electricity our security and defense
editor Deborah Haynes is in Odessa and
Deborah I mean the the Sun is up where
you are but when the power is off and
the night falls it must be pretty grim
it is very Grim it's more about the
length of time as well that the the
power is going out the country has been
bombarded by Russia since October in a
deliberate strategy to take out the
power infrastructure and it means that
they're having to restrict the power
that they do have and then Engineers are
working Round the Clock trying to
reconnect the grid there was this um
this strike on at the early hours of
Saturday using Iranian drones that the
Russians have bought it would seem
against this port city over here and
like you said the president said that
1.5 million people were left without
power now come yesterday evening the
power was back on in the center of the
city but we went to a residential block
on the outskirts where we met people
that were literally sitting inside their
cars as this one young couple huddled in
their dressing gowns smiling still
despite the inconvenience and saying
that even if Russia as is expected
continues with this policy of time
turning people's homes into a sort of
front line on the energy War they're
going to resist and this all comes we
mustn't forget as there is horrendous
fighting continuing in the east of the
country as Russian forces beaten back in
parts of the southeast in parts of the
South are desperately trying to take the
town of bakmut Ukrainian forces are
trying to hold the line there but there
are devastating fights going on the
casualties are horrendously High the
weather is very cold it's incredibly
grim
Deborah many thanks indeeds
let's take a look at some of these other
headlines now
and it is now known that five people
lost their lives after an explosion and
fire at a block of flats in Jersey it's
also emerged that firefighters even cult
the flats hours before the blast
Emergency Services were there to
investigate claims of a gas leak
a man who killed his wife almost 40
years ago will become the first prisoner
to have a public parole board here in
the UK
Richard sorry Russell Causley I should
say was handed a life sentence for
murdering cow packman in 1985. he was
freed from prison in 2020 after serving
more than 23 years of the murder but was
returned to jail in November last year
Energy prices in the UK have soared to
record Heights with the code snap set to
cause a spike in demand reduced wind
generation is also affecting Supply the
day ahead price for power to be
delivered on Monday reached a record
675 pounds a megawatt hour
and let's take a look at what's ahead
for this freezing weather joined by Sky
meteorologist Steph galter Steph good to
see you I'm good to see you wrapped up
warm as well I mean just just how bad
was it last night I saw temperatures
-15 well in a part of the country that I
know well
yeah minus 16 we got to in Bremer and
Scotland very very cold um
where it wasn't quite that bad we
generally had minus fours to minus
sevens in parts of Scotland and then we
did have one or two isolated sort of
minus four in parts of Wales and England
but the main story of course last night
was that snow we've got this huge area
of low pressure over us at the moment
it's quite weak and flabby but it's got
one or two little weather systems within
it sort of like dying fronts if you will
and that one just popped up from from
the English Channel and gave us loads of
snow in the Southeast corner so London
also further east than that and that's
where we got the worst of the snow the
the official
recording for the amount of snow was
around nine centimeters but some places
did say they got 12 centimeters so
that's the kind of amount of snow which
for the southeast corner is a lot
um fortunately today it doesn't look
like there's going to be a great deal
more wintry weather so the snow
shouldn't be so bad today instead what
we're going to see as we head through
the night is some freezing fall Vlog and
that will cause us different problems of
course on the roads it makes it very
difficult to get about and as we head
through the next few days does it get
any better Neil well unfortunately it
doesn't if anything we've got a renewed
Arctic blast as we head through
Wednesday Thursday that will hit
Northern Scotland we can expect plenty
of snow there and elsewhere staying very
very cold very very cold indeed Steph
many thanks get inside and get yourself
a cup of tea
uh no some of the photos catching our
eye today and I'm sorry to say it
football may not be coming home
but this little fella is uh his name is
Dave the cat and he's been adopted by
England's football team Sweet Little
Thing uh Dave won their hearts whilst
hanging out at the team's hotel in Doha
uh no no here is a shot of a SpaceX
Falcon 9 rocket which lifted up from
Cape Canaveral early yesterday with a
commercial Japanese robotic moonlander
and a NASA hitchhiker micro payload
called lunar flashlight that will be
seeking out signs of water ice hidden in
the permanently dark floors of craters
at the moon's poles what will it
discover we'll keep our fingers crossed
anyway stay where you are the man who
was in charge of the U.S investigation
into the Lockerbie disaster will be
giving us his tick on the arrest of the
suspected bombing
foreign
[Music]
welcome back reminder as to our top
stories this hour and four children
remain in a critical condition after
falling through the ice into a lake in
Solon specialist divers are searching
the water for anyone else we need to
listen
have you snort and Ice has brought the
M25 to a standstill through the night
drivers have been described have been
describing and stuck in their cars for
hours on end
and ministers have made unofficial
requests for the military to drive
ambulances during the strikes
Now GPS want the government to publish
clearer advice about strep a for parents
as doctors struggle to deal with an
outbreak linked to the deaths of at
least 15 children now at Dr Jonathan
Cohen is a consultant in pediatric
infectious diseases at Evelina London
children's hospital and as you can see
joins us now doctor great to have you on
um we need to pour an awful lot of
calming oil on some pretty Troubled
Waters but but let's start with the the
most significant question what is strepi
and what do parents need to be keeping
an eye out for so group a Streptococcus
or strep a is a bacteria and it's very
commonly carried in children so it's
about one in Ten school children will
actually have this bacteria in their
throat and the fact that it's that
common I think that really tells us that
for the vast majority of children who
have strep a they will have no problems
whatsoever sometimes it can cause sore
throats often referred to as strep
throats and again that's usually a mild
illness sometimes with a fever
more rather than that is something
called scarlet fever where children can
develop a quite a bright red rash on a
pail of skin often with a sandpapery
rough texture to it often with the
changes in their tongue as well what
where I think the concern comes in is
the more much much rarer but more severe
invasive group a strap which is when the
bacteria actually gets into the
bloodstream or into the lungs and can
then cause very serious disease eye
gases I think invasive glucose so so
when that happens what is it the parent
should be looking out for because
because ultimately parents know their
children better than their their medical
practitioner better than their GP we
know when there is something wrong so
but specifically when should the alarm
Bells be ringing so exactly I'd
completely agree with that and this
isn't a new infection so in a sense the
ways in which a parent would recognize
their child would have a serious illness
is no different from group a strep so
the things to be looking the things
where you'd have immediate concern and
want to call 999 or get to an emergency
department as soon as possible will be
if there was worries about the child's
breathing irregular breathing difficulty
breathing pauses in the breathing if
their collar didn't look right in their
tongue and their lips if it was blue or
gray and hands and feet looking an
abnormal color that would raise great
concern a child who's difficult to Rouse
very very sleepy lethargy that's that's
the one thing yeah extreme letharging
they're the very worrying symptoms that
suggests that they have a serious
infection and that's a time to call 999
or get to the emergency department so
what is what is the treatment in those
kind of across the board I mean
antibiotic strikes means is kind of
there's the first Port of Call isn't it
absolutely so for these very very rare
cases of invasive group a strap eye gas
antibiotics are the Mainstay of
treatment and they're given
intravenously the majority of children
who have a disease as a result of strep
won't have eye gas and they can be
treated with oral antibiotics instead
and in fact many children with the most
mildest forms of streptococcal infection
get better by themselves even without
antibiotics are we aging closer to
working out why we have seen so so many
deaths linked to strappy look as I
understand it we do see them every year
a handful of them and I'm not sure if we
have a statistically significant enough
data set yet to make this to make this
point but it feels as if there are more
this year than there have been in
previous years so I'd agree and very
much it's an evolving situation and it's
very difficult at the moment to draw
firm conclusions about what exactly is
causing the changes that are happening
what we do know though looking back over
many decades is that there is a there
are years every three or four years of
greater numbers of group a strep
infection in all its forms scarlet fever
and eye gas we also know that it changes
seasonally during the course of the year
so you'll get a rise often as the winter
moves into spring and then it settles
down again we've seen this year that
rise seems to be occurring earlier and
at higher rates and I think we just need
to watch what happens over the coming
weeks and months maybe this is something
that's going to settle itself down
perhaps with school breaks and things
perhaps it's going to carry on a bit
longer but you know compared to previous
years the numbers are not entirely
disproportionate and I think that's
really important to remember
especially that the symptoms of this are
symptoms that are very very common in
mild childhood illnesses parents know
their children best and I would think
they should draw on their own instincts
in determine what to do I mean I suppose
the the one thing about the covert
pandemic is it appears to have turned
everyone into amateur epidemiologists
amateur doctors and there is an awful
lot of speculation particularly on
social media that the restrictions the
lockdown the lack of social mixing that
we had the particularly children had
during that period has perhaps somehow
contributed to all of this what's your
review so I think it's certainly
contributed to why we're seeing so many
viral infections going around in
children at the moment of as everyone
knows every parent certainly recognizes
the winter is the time when children
often have many coughs and colds
children won't have had as many over
previous years not just because of
lockdowns but because of all the other
social distancing
um lower amounts of mixing compared to
normal increased amounts of hand washing
increased amounts of hand sanitization
all of this has been going on for a
while and a lot of that has been relaxed
as 2022's gone on so in some ways it's
no surprise there's a lot more viral
infections you put that in the mix with
a every few years rise of group a strep
in some ways it isn't so surprising that
we are seeing a greater number of cases
at the moment very very briefly if we're
trying to avoid strappy what's what is
the best advice so the best way to well
the best way to avoid strep a is by your
standard means of hand washing in a
normal way hygiene around coughing and
sneezing and blowing noses but I would
remind everyone that the vast majority
of people who catch the strep a bacteria
will not be coming well at all and the
the vast majority of them will have
caught it many many times in the past
without even knowing it very reassuring
Dr Cohen thanks very much for being with
us
I'd like to turn our attention back to
that Arctic blast my colleague Sarah
Jane me managed to find herself stranded
in the snow on the roadside last night
and Sarah Jane joins us now our
nine-year-old Ted who was stuck with her
in the snow along with baby sister Ray
hi guys I mean first things first SJ I
mean I don't suspect you ever thought
you'd be up on Breakfast early at this
time in the morning this must be a bit
of a shock to the system but tell us
what happened
I was I'm so tired but the producer
Texas here we were still asleep where we
wanted you
so we went and my sister lives about 20
minutes away so we're in um East Sussex
and my sister lives in Kent sounds a
long way but it's only about 20 minutes
away in the car isn't it so he popped
over for a cup of tea about
I did about three o'clock yeah probably
probably about three o'clock and Uncle
Marco is Canadian isn't he said it's
snowing and he said you better move
quick because we were in a really small
car yeah and
yeah yeah we were in a small car so we
set off and the snow was coming down
really fast and like I said it's only 20
minutes but we're having to eat along so
this this picture here is actually
that's the hill where we got stuff isn't
it tell us what happened on the hill so
we got stuck on the hill
and everyone
so it was sort of really cool
then as we were driving
everyone started to like stop and we
started to like fall behind skid into
bushes
when we were skidding into the bushes
it looks really stuck and then people
with bigger cars thought they could make
it but they just drove in front of us
and just could just stopped moving so it
was so frustrating because we were on a
hill and lucky it was a residential Hill
and everybody was coming out that lives
on there because obviously they've seen
this before and we're Towing people up
the hill but somebody sort of everybody
kept trying to get in front of us so we
kept moving down the list so we went
from being really excited about the snow
didn't we tend to how did we feel in
that car just
so how long were you guys actually stuck
for
um like a couple hours a couple of hours
we were stuck we were stuck for about
four so what happened was this again
this picture with a blue car this is an
abandoned car in front of us so we
abandoned that car didn't we because who
did we meet because we met
some snow angels some snow angels we
call them snow angels um Cheryl and
Jason who if they're listening this
morning I hope they got there they were
on their way to Rye on the a21 so
basically that's where it all service
from the a21 that goes through Kent East
Sussex down to sort of Hastings way it
was just completely gridlocked the snow
came down so quickly cars were abandoned
everywhere nobody could get back could
they so Cheryl and Jason came to our car
saw that we had baby Ray in there who
she was pretty good actually wasn't she
considering she's only a night in your
car and and they gave us a lift to the
main road and then who was our big snow
angel at the end my dad yeah dressed
like he was going skiing and he managed
to get us onto the a21 he was just
appropriately we weren't where we did we
had trainers on and then we got to the
a21 and we were there for another hour
or so and we literally just live off the
a21 but it went as far as the eye could
see and I was following a lady on
Twitter I hope she's okay I checked it
this morning when I woke up and at about
2 A.M she said she'd only just turned
off the a21 it was bad wasn't it yeah it
was
terrible but how do you feel we got home
I felt really good because it was Rey's
first experience in the snow and when
she was in the snow she was running
around and picking it up even though she
did get a bit wet because of the snow
Yeah we'd been in the car a long time so
I let them stretch their legs and run
about in the snow that they've been
desperate to be and we've just been
stuck in a car and that's our garden
this morning I mean that's unbelievable
at four o'clock yesterday afternoon
nothing and then all of that was falling
overnight I'm sensing a snowball fight
coming at just a little bit later on yes
this is me officially calling it a snow
day Neil
not a chance um I know you will have
kept you'll you'll get the Wee Ones um
spirits up but you know raise up raise
our Eon a very very wee one you must
have been a little bit worried yeah well
we were a little bit do you want to go
and get rated actually yeah yeah go and
get ready to bring her in and she can
she can sort of say hello um
obviously
um you have to keep calm in the car so
it was a bit panicky because like I said
my sister only lives 20 minutes down the
road and even though we knew snow was
coming it was forecast for later that
night and we just got caught out I feel
really stupid
um not enough snacks in the car for kids
luckily they had warm coats on but it
was a real big lesson I've always lived
in the city this is my first winter out
of town and we just got caught out even
though we thought it was do you want to
come say hello to Uncle Neil
foreign
weren't as lucky
at like I I suspect you've got your
hands full a little bit this morning and
uh yeah someone probably wants to get
out probably wants to get out and enjoy
the snow for a little bit so we'll let
you go
I just want you to give me a wave before
you go Ray and please look back yourself
big wave
thank you
take care guys and have a lovely
Christmas when it comes
okay see you now thank you
uh time to take a very quick break and
of course afterwards we will update you
as to the conditions on the roads on the
public transport Network and indeed at
the very latest from solo last night
[Music]
welcome back South Korea's prime
minister has told Sky News that North
Korea is approaching the final stages
for another nuclear test and Doc Sue
spoke to our Asia correspondent Helen
Ann Smith
uh it'll be somewhat hard to know
exactly when they will actually do the
things that all the International
Community would like to see them not to
do
but
we We Gather that they are ready to do
something
and you know our allies and partners are
totally on a lot for that kind of
situations uh but although we do not
know exactly when but we gather that
they are
prepared for that kind of you know you
know the testing
foreign
specific here what is the warning from
the south Koreans exactly what is it
that the North Koreans are just about to
be able to do
well the South Korean prime minister was
very very clear in that interview that
they are pretty convinced that North
Korea is preparing to undertake another
full test of a nuclear weapon now that
would be very significant indeed because
North Korea haven't done something like
that since 2017 and it comes at a time
of massively increased tensions on the
Korean peninsula there have been more
missile launches from North Korea this
year than at any other year since Kim
Jong-un the current leader of North
Korea came to power and the Prime
Minister there was very clear in that
interview with me that they believe that
those tests are being prepared for and
that one will come he said he couldn't
say exactly when but the implication was
very much that they think that will be
soon and of course that will be deeply
uh escalatory not least because the
South Koreans have previously insinuated
that if that happened it'd be very
difficult for them not to respond
um in some way the other thing that has
changed this year as opposed to back in
2017 when the last nuclear test happened
is that the current South Korean
Administration is quite new uh president
Yoon just got elected earlier this year
and he ran on a platform where he
promised to be much more hawkish when it
came to the North Korean issue his
predecessor uh pushed for talks pushed
for diplomacy although it was obviously
always a little stilted and didn't get
that far but but this President is
making a point of being harder so so
what that then leads to how it escalates
is a slightly more open question and a
slightly more open concern frankly the
other thing that he indicated as well he
spoke about Kim jong-un's daughter who's
been seen in public for the first time
in the last couple of nuclear tests
whether that's potentially a hint to
some sort of succession he said he
couldn't say but he thinks that it's
very significant and a real message that
that daughter was bought out as she has
been so uh really interesting lines at a
very tense time on the Korean peninsula
incredibly tender Helena many thanks
indeed
some other news now and at least two
people have been killed in violence
during the latest protests in Peru
calling for early elections
Patrick Steele was removed from office
and arrested after an impeachment trial
his successor has conceded to
demonstrate his demands I should say
announcing she'll ask Congress to move
elections forward
three people including a friend of the
Italian Prime Minister Giorgio Maloney
had been killed after a man opened fire
at a meeting of apartment block
residents in Rome Ms Malona paid tribute
to the victim Nicoletta golisano posting
a picture on Instagram a 57 year old man
has been arrested
Serbia's President says he'll do
everything to preserve peace and Kosovo
but has warned his country's Army is
ready to defend if needed in recent
weeks sarabs in Northern Kosovo which
they believe to be part of Serbia have
responded with violent resistance to
moves by Kosovo that they see as
anti-serve
and let's return to that incident in
solihull near Birmingham where four
children fell through the ice into a
lake leaving them fighting for their
lives others may also be missing after
falling in well joining us now is Katie
cornhill head a training for Learning
and Development at East Sussex fire and
rescue service
um Katie it's good to have you on this
morning but I suspect like me when you
first heard about this story a chill ran
down your spine it's absolutely horrible
isn't it
yes good morning yes thank you uh yes it
is it is a very awful uh situation or
awful event uh emergency that we've
attended in circumstances and certainly
our thoughts um in East Sussex Farm
Rescue are with the uh people involved
and uh particularly the families and the
emergency uh responders that had to
attend such an incident
yeah our correspondent Becky was on the
scene said that she had never seen so
many First Responders at an instant so
you know our hearts go out to them our
thoughts are with them as well it's a it
is a difficult job to do but on an
occasion such as this just just walk us
through what the the process would be
because of course you know the First
Responders would be putting themselves
at risk going anywhere near that water
as well
um so we would uh approach an incident
like this in a quick time as possible
but very safely at the same time we'd be
trying to secure uh casualties that we
can secure immediately where they need a
rescuing not putting ourselves in danger
and making sure that no one else is
putting themselves in danger when we
attend incidents like this often there
is the initial casualty who may have
gone through some ice but there is often
subsequent casualties that will go uh go
through the ice because they're trying
to rescue them and we do come across
incidents like this one where there's
groups of people uh playing uh on ice or
on ice when they probably should not be
indeed well I mean leaving aside the
obvious advice is we just do not go on
to to ice on legs if someone is in a
position where they see something like
this happen what is the advice what can
they do is it just simply a matter of
call 999 and and trying to keep yourself
safe
so very first thing to do is exactly
what you've said uh shout for help phone
999 the two most important things to do
uh if the casualty
um isn't too far away uh you shouldn't
you shouldn't attempt to rescue them
anyway and certainly wait for the
Emergency Services but calm them and
reassure them whilst you're at the ER
scene with them uh shout to the casualty
all the time keep talking to them uh
encourage them to keep still offer
reassurance and and just try to calm
them down as much as you can you you can
attempt to reach them obviously not by
um walking on the ice or trying to get
on the ice but you could use anything
that you can find that's around you
could tie clothes together you could use
a tree branch if there's rope or
anything like that available or a
flotation device uh you can try and
reach them from the bank best advice is
lay down uh on the side of the bank to
avoid being pulled in as well so and
that of course spreads your weight on
the bank
um if you can't reach them uh just as I
say find something to throw to them even
a football will help to keep them float
if they've gone uh they've gone through
the ice
didn't even think of something as as
simple as that and briefly Katie if you
can when someone goes through the ice
and it's immediately submerged in in you
know freezing cold water what are the
consequences the health consequences
well the immediate consequence is
obviously very serious uh the cold shock
that you get it will affect your body
immediately
um and you'll start to breathe much more
rapidly because of the shock of the
water and the longer you stay in that
water and that cold condition uh the
more effect there is immediately on your
cardiovascular system
Katie I'm so sorry but we're literally
got 10 seconds left in the program we
will clip this interview up and put it
on our social media channels everyone
can take your advice there but Kitty
can't help thanks so much for being with
us
my pleasure thank you
[Music]